Falling under the category of “What could
go wrong?” is the sport of ferret legging.
Simple in its design although painful to master,
the sport simply requires a man, a pair of
baggy trousers and two live ferrets.
The trousers are secured at the ankles, and,
after the ferrets are set free in them, secured
at the waist as well.
Underwear of any kind is prohibited, and the
animals must be free to roam from leg to leg.
Neither the contestants nor the animals may
be drugged or drunk.
After the match begins, the contestants stand
in front of the judges and the last man standing
(they’re pretty much always men) wins.
Note that the ferrets must have a full set
of claws and teeth, and neither can be filed
or blunted in any way.
Between these, they can wreak a fair amount
of havoc on delicate human flesh, particularly
once their instincts to bite and dig kick
in.
Plus, as with other carnivores, once the victim
(or rather, contestant) begins bleeding, the
ferret’s blood lust can trigger attempts
to feed.
The sport has unknown origins but at the least
was partially popularized by coal miners in
Yorkshire, England in the 1970s, and for several
years the ferret legging record stayed (understandably)
under two minutes.
Then, in 1977, Edward Simpkins is said to
have set a new record in excess of five hours;
however, for the first four hours he only
had one animal in his pants.
Undoubtedly, the greatest ferret legger of
all time is Reg Mellor, a retired Yorkshire
miner, who set the record at five hours and
26 minutes on July 5, 1981.
Employing ferrets to hunt in the open valleys
around his home for many years, Mellor claimed
that he had routinely kept the animals in
his trousers to keep them dry and warm when
it rained.
He said part of the secret to his success
was to feed the ferrets well before putting
them in his pants.
That’s not to say the ferrets didn’t do
their share of damage to him.
After dropping his drawers for a reporter
doing a story on Reg, it was observed that
his legs were “crosshatched with scars.”
When asked if the ferrets ever bit his more
sensitive bits, Reg replied, “I had ’em
hangin’ from me tool for hours an’ hours
an’ hours!”
And that another key to becoming a champion
at this particular sport is to “be able
to have your tool bitten and not care.”
Reg’s near three decade run as the record
holder in ferret legging was finally ended
in May of 2010 by Frank Bartlett of Whittington,
England who set the new record at five hours
and 30 minutes, using the sport as a fundraising
opportunity for his village’s first responders.